hey it's Justine and today we are
checking out the brand new iPhone 15.
we've got the Plus in green and the
regular iPhone 15 in pink which
obviously we know that I'm excited about
now a lot of people are saying that this
year's release was a little bit
underwhelming and I actually think that
this is probably Apple's most impressive
base model release that they've had in a
really long time and here's why
[Music]
first of all I think the actual physical
design of this new iPhone is really
under hyped this new design with the
rounded edges and the matte glass back
completely changes the feel of the phone
in your hand it's a big departure from
the sharp edges and glossy finish of the
previous models which has a huge impact
overall on the feel of this device it
feels super premium and with the new
color infused glass it looks really
amazing too I can't remember the last
time that a base model iPhone felt and
looked this good and of course one of
the biggest and most anticipated changes
to the iPhone's design is the move to
USBC this has been such a long time
coming and to finally have this
connectivity is really awesome being
able to charge multiple Apple devices
with a single cable is going to make the
whole experience so much more
streamlined now there is a difference
between the regular iPhones and iPhone
15 Pros the iPhone 15 just has USB 2.0
speeds and the pros have USBC 3.0 speeds
which is much faster for data transfer
which is something that we'll definitely
be using in those Pro phones because we
can now shoot in prores log and some of
those files can tend to be on the larger
side so we'll be able to transfer them
much quicker the iPhone 15 comes in two
sizes with a 6.1 inch and 6.7 inch super
retina XTR display with super durable
ceramic shield glass it comes in five
colors pink yellow green blue and black
and they all look so nice the colors are
really subtle but also vibrant at the
same time if that makes any sense it's a
little tough to describe but I'm such a
big fan and obviously the pink finish is
my favorite
[Music]
thank you now along with the changes to
the hardware design the iPhone 15 has
been upgraded with many pro features of
last year's Pro Models it now has the 48
megapixel main camera that we got with
the iPhone 14 pro it shoots super high
resolution photos and with that
resolution you get three different
Optical quality Zoom levels an ultra
wide Lens regular lens and a 2X lens
that all produce photos with Incredible
detail and all of these cameras are made
better by sensorship Optical image
stabilization
foreign
[Music]
this allows you to get some super
detailed Zoom shots and you can zoom in
very smoothly optically and digitally
switching between the lenses something
else that is a really cool option is
they now have a hype Max photo option so
when you have this turned on you have
the ability to take the full 48
megapixel images but it's not in that
huge raw file size that you'll see on
the pros with this for most people
they're going to be super happy with the
output
foreign
[Music]
night mode and portraits have new
upgrades as well so night mode will
activate automatically in dark scenes
and with a new high-res camera colors
and detail come through so much better
now this is true for portrait mode as
well and now after you've taken a
portrait you can tap into the image to
change the focus from one subject to
another this is pretty awesome it's ice
cream time this is the first video that
I'm filming on the new iPhone 15 and of
course we have to get a little mint
chocolate chip to match the new well I'm
gonna call it mint green foam if they
don't have mint chip I'm going to be so
upset
[Music]
thank you
foreign
15 review to bring you a word from our
sponsor Rhino Shield they sent me so
many cases to check out for my new
iPhone 15 and a discount code for all of
you guys if you want to check out some
of their new cases and some of their
older cases for previous gens you can
use iJustine for 10 off at checkout they
also have cases for Apple watches
airpods and again if you aren't
upgrading and getting a new phone this
year you can upgrade with cases from
some previous generations I mean there
are so many to choose from they're
magsafe compatible have an 11 foot drop
protection with their shock spread
technology and 360 degrees of protection
it's also cool that they're clear cases
come with a five year warranty against
yellowing or discoloration they have a
lot of new colors for the iPhone 15 and
even an improved grip on solid suitcases
I also love these 3D impact screens they
have a transparency one and a privacy
shield to protect your screen from
sneaky eyes trying to see what's on your
screen the mod NX are really fun because
they allow you to accessorize your clear
cases with different bumpers they also
sent this Aqua stand that I'm so excited
to test out it's a water model but it
also has a MAG save flip on the top so
if you're somebody who likes to film
your workouts in the gym this is
definitely the water bottle for you flip
it up put the phone on it and that's it
again for 10 off you can use iJustine at
checkout I'll put a link in the
description thank you again to Rhino
Shield for sponsoring a portion of this
video
foreign
[Music]
was basically staged for the shot I
gotta eat it like this
Shogun
so happy
the iPhone 15 also now has Dynamic
Island last year's base models were
still rocking the old school Notch at
the top of the screen but now all of the
models get to enjoy this added
functionality now if you're not already
familiar with it Dynamic Island takes
what used to be just black cutout for
the front camera and sensors and it uses
that space to display alerts and live
activities so when you get a call or you
order food or things like that you'll
get these cool Dynamic animations
something else I'm excited about is this
new integration with iOS 17 called name
drop so you can bring your phones close
together just like this and you can
instantly share your contact information
now I use airdrop all the time so I love
that in iOS 17 airdrop is now taking
advantage of Wi-Fi and cellular so if
I'm airdropping a file and I happen to
not be close to that phone anymore as I
Venture off into the world I can
continue sending this through cellular
or sending it through the internet when
I get home to Wi-Fi something else
that's really fun is FaceTime voicemail
so if I don't answer a call like this
call from Tyler that's coming in and I
decide to ignore it he can actually
leave me a voicemail video
because we have to shoot so just let me
know call me back thanks bye I also
really like the live voicemail
transcription I don't like talking on
the phone really so I get a lot of
voicemails because everyone knows that I
don't answer my phone so this is cool
because I can watch the voicemail text
transcribe itself live and decide if
it's actually important and I have to
answer hello are you okay
[Music]
okay bye
empowering all of this is of course
Apple's a16 bionic chip and this is the
same chip that we had in last year's Pro
Models so the iPhone 15 is getting a big
performance upgrade this is a six core
CPU with two performance cores and four
efficiency cores which is what creates
all that power and performance while
keeping great battery life it also has a
5 Core GPU and 16 core Enduro engine
power and computational photography and
Graphics intensive activities like
gaming so that's it for the iPhone 15s
this was a really fun review to do
because I'm really impressed with how
incredible these phones are this year
and like I said the design change and
everything about them is pretty exciting
so if you're looking to upgrade from an
older phone and you don't think that the
pro is for you I'm confident that the
base model iPhone 15s are something that
you're going to be super hyped about if
you want to check out more videos they
are here at the end and of course
subscribe hit the Bell to be notified
when I post new videos and leave me some
comments below I can't wait to hear from
you bye